being of Eric Stonestreet I understand
you took quite a trip with him recently
yeah I went to k-state Manhattan Kansas
with him he his alma mater is alma mater
and we spoke with some of the the
students we did a kind of a talk back
with them and then afterwards we went
bar-hopping an Aggie bill which is you
know the strip of bars there and um it
denied ended with Eric saying let's go
back to let's go to my frat house so
this is like 2:30 in the morning and we
just randomly go to the front I think it
was pipe the pike frat house and we
knocked on the door 2:30 in the morning
they opened the door and here's he's
like - you know people from television
iconic characters if you ask me and and
they they were so thrown off like what
are you doing here they had just thrown
this huge party where they basically
trashed the frat house um it's it's some
ritual I don't know why they did they
were there apologetic but how it looked
I was like this is exactly what I was
expecting it to look like it's
disgusting and they're like I love
something I love you in a frat house
yeah we all gonna clean this up
immediately yellow gloves is like Claire
and and so then and then we were walking
in the hallway and found Eric's photo on
the wall and then he's like let's go
into my old my old room so he just opens
up a room that he used to live in and
there was a man in there with his lady
friend and they were under the sheets
doing naughty naughty things and you
Chewie we come into the room they like
like hey
and she's like covering herself up with
the sheet and then they're like oh my
god can we get a picture with you guys
we took photos with that you took photo
he surprised with that yeah we have the
photos let's take another one - we're
good
that's fantastic I mean she like got all
gussied up and dress up did our hair and
put some makeup on came back out she's
like can I get a real one now it's like
being clothed yes it was fun now that's
fast not with the one that's going on TV
no no
you